bonjour avoue jérôme rodriguez merci
d'être avec nous en direct ce matin sur
rtl france 12 septembre prochain un
appel a été donc lancés sur les réseaux
sociaux
l'objectif de cette mobilisation
l'objectif de cette mobilisation c'est
de rappeler l'ensemble des
revendications à la base de ddj les
jeunes qui était celle du 17 novembre de
revenir à ce qui était notre coeur de
métier de pouvoir revendiquer et de
pouvoir proposer des solutions sur ce
qui se passe aujourd'hui en france c'est
aussi l'objectif ce sera aussi de
relancer on imagina le mouvement alors
ce terme relancer on l'entend depuis
déjà un an et demi avec tous les
synonymes le mouvement s'essouffle le
monde le mouvement manque d'air mais on
part on connait on parle continuellement
du mouvement des gilets jaunes à savoir
que même pendant le coc vide
le pendule on appelle ça pendant le le
confinement on a on a été on a été très
actif sur les réseaux sociaux on a su
être présent dans la rue tout de suite à
la sortie du confinement donc je
commence un peu à en avoir assez qu'on
parle au passé les gilet jaune est
toujours se rappeler au bon souvenir des
médias alors je sais que rta l'habitude
de parler de nous et je ne vous implique
pas dans ce schéma
mais les gilets jaunes sont bel et bien
présents sont bel et bien actif et
aujourd'hui je le répète à défaut
d'avoir peur des gilet jaune en cette
date du 12 septembre
il faudrait peut-être avoir peur de plus
ceux qui vont arriver sur le marché de
la misère vous avez des licenciements
pagaille vous avez sept cent mille
jeunes qui arrivent sur le marché du
travail sur un marché du travail
quasiment inexistant donc aujourd'hui et
en date du 12 septembre il sera bon de
rappeler à ce nouveau gouvernement qui
aujourd'hui surf sur la vague des 100
jours en distribuant des milliards à
tous les côtés et en se baladant un peu
partout en france pour faire ne
serait-ce que de la communication
il est important de se rappeler au bon
souvenir de monsieur qu'axe castex car
apparemment il a pas l'air de connaître
les gilet jaune parce que reviennent les
proposer aux revendications qu'on peut
apporter qui sont celles du mieux vivre
je le rappelle d'une démocratie directe
et participative la fin des privilèges
de nos gouvernants et bien entendu plus
qui est sur le terrain des violences
policières
donc il est important qu'on se conçoit
présent et on sera présent et je vous
garantis qu'il n'y aura pas que des
gilets jaunes d'oeufs je suis assez
central dans le mouvement des vies les
gens pour vous dire
le mécontentement et la colère qui va
arriver en septembre elle ne sera pas de
gilet jaune elle sera d'abord citoyenne
car l'ensemble des citoyens aujourd'hui
sont concernés par nos revendications et
par ce qui se passe en france sera pas
seulement un mouvement gilet jaune sera
un mouvement citoyen est ce que vous
appelez la convergence jérôme rodriguez
et on vit dans une époque assez
particulière il ya cette pandémie le
mouvement aussi black like the matters
ou aux états unis
les dénonciations des violences
policières du racisme aussi il ya une
rentrée sociale importante qui s'annonce
est ce que vous appelez à la convergence
des luttes
alors au bout d'un an et demi je
m'aperçus que la convergence est très
très compliqué parce que je me suis
aperçu que l'ensemble des groupes
d'action et des groupes qui sont lutte
que vous avez pu citer auparavant ont
tous le même objectif
il est difficile d'avoir une convergence
à savoir que la convergence non plus que
ces groupes de lutte sont plus prophète
du chemin à prendre mais la finalité est
la même donc je parlerai peut-être plus
d'unions d'une union citoyenne parce
qu'avant d'être gilet jaune on est des
citoyens qui portant un gilet jaune de
pouvoir s'unir dans un dans un but
commun celui de pouvoir améliorer notre
qualité de vie où ils sont tous en tout
cas éviter de la dégrader comme est en
train de faire le gouvernement
actuellement il est important que la
france se réveille il est important que
les français se réveille et qu'on donne
du crédit aux travailleurs et en
français et surtout à tous ces français
qui ont tenu la france à bout de bras
c'est la première fois en un an et demi
quoi qu'on en dise quoi qu'on en pense
que je lance un anglais un événement que
j'organise un événement que je demande à
l'ensemble des groupes d'action gilet
jaune et autres citoyens de pouvoir
corps organisés et de retrouver cette
union qu'on avait le 17 novembre de
pouvoir s'inscrire dans dans une
manifestation à la fois pacifique
revendicatrice et avec l'apport de
solutions aujourd'hui il est grand temps
de rappeler à monsieur macron qui a
proposé moult rendez-vous à différents
gilet jaune comme à sandrine lors du du
salon de l'agriculture où nous avons
envoyé des courriers pour pouvoir être
reçu et nous avons des fins de non
recevoir
donc vous avez aujourd'hui l'ensemble de
dix ministres qui se baladent en france
qui sont prêts à rencontrer l'ensemble
des français sauf cette catégorie de
citoyens avant tout mais qui porta gilet
jaune
donc on sera là le 12 septembre je
prends les risques de pouvoir
c'est cet appel d'autres personnes vont
nous rejoindre d'autres groupes ou vont
nous rejoindre pour pouvoir faire
évoluer les choses et ne pas sans cesse
parler d'un co gide qui aujourd'hui
embête les français et qui empêche de
livres les français et on le voit sur le
terrain ça fait plusieurs semaines que
je fais le tour de france que je m'amuse
à aller voir l'ensemble des
contestataires de france et qui sont
fatigués de cette situation et qui
voudrait avoir des réponses et surtout
des solutions chose qu'aujourd'hui le
gouvernement est incapable de nous
apporter à savoir qu'un gouvernement qui
aujourd'hui est incapable de porc
apporter des réponses aux français ne va
utiliser qu'un système de violence et de
répression
à défaut de pouvoir s'installer autour
d'une table et de pouvoir discuter
jérôme rodriguez on craint une deuxième
vague de l'épidémie sera peut-être
encore le cas en septembre on ne sait
pas dans ce contexte là comment vous
allez vous organiser le 12 septembre
et quel est le programme précisément
alors écouter s'il ya une deuxième vague
i lya je sortirai ma planche de cirque
qui gérait faire du surf
parce que à un moment donné et deuxième
vague deuxième vague deuxième vague
qu'est ce qu'on en sait on a pas de
vaccin on a pas de tests on n'a pas de
solution et on est là toujours nous dire
il va y avoir une deuxième bague moi je
pense qu'on essaye d'installer un climat
de peur au sein des français pour
pouvoir toujours mieux les les les
rendre dociles et coopératif vient à un
gouvernement qui aujourd'hui ne maîtrise
plus rien moi j'ai des doutes alors
attention on va dire que rodrigues est
un complotiste je me positionnement des
questions où l action du gouvernement
vis-à-vis de ce virus
quand on voit ce qui se passe
actuellement moi j'essaie l'été on est
on a l'occasion de pouvoir se promener
je discute avec pas mal de commerçants
à défaut de ce qu'on peut penser que les
commerçants déteste les gilet jaune et
ils en ont assez de cette situation ils
sont fatigués de cette situation et
surtout de ne pas pouvoir pouvoir gagner
leur argent aujourd'hui et c'est ça qui
est très très compliqué merci à vous
j'ai roma rodriguez d'avoir répondu en
direct 1 ce matin sur rtl france